[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les révolutions du monde arabe ont
suscité d'immenses
espoirs au nom de la justice social et
de la liberté les peuples de Tunisie
d'Égypte de Libye chassai leur
[Musique]
dictateurs dans les rues sur les places
des printemps arabes des femmes des
jeunes diplômés des citadins des jeunes
des campagnes ou des usines app la
[Applaudissements]
démocra le temps était à l'allesse mais
à la guerre aussi les révolutionnaires
filmaient les manifestations comme les
émeutes ou les assauts avec leur
téléphone portable et postait les vidéos
sur
Internet le monde suivait fasciné le
réveil de ses peuples ses révolutions
2.0 2 ans après le temps de l'espoir
semble loin dans tous les pays le chaos
s'est installé que sont devenus les
rêves de liberté de démocratie de
justice sociale que reste-t-il des
slogans des printemps arabes de
2011 l'idéal révolutionnaire a-t-il été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trahi
les révolutions arabes ont commencé le
17 décembre 2010 en Tunisie quand un
vendeur ambulance par le feu devant le
bureau du gouverneur de la petite ville
de bousine il venait comme tous les
matins de remplir sa charette des fruits
et légumes qu'il venait vendre à la
sauvette le seul métier qu'il avait
trouvé pour survivre comme beaucoup de
jeunes de cette province rurale du
centre de la
Tunisie par son geste par son désespoir
il a incarné la crise du monde rural la
honte de tous ces jeunes de vivre dans
la misère sans
avenir son geste désespéré
elle est un celle des printemps arabes
elle allumera la révolte les premières
manifestations que rien ne pourra
la vague de protestation née à Sid bide
est reprise par les villes ouvrières
puis gagne Tunis en quelques
[Applaudissements]
jours ce sont des jeunes d'abord qui
n'appartiennent ni à des partis ni à des
organisations syndical mais qui
comprennent la détresse de bois ils sont
vite soutenus par les avocats puis par
tout le
dans la rue les Tunisiens grisés par
leur nombre découvrent la puissance de
la foule en
colère dans ce petit pays du Maghreb la
dictature était insupportable le
président Ben Ali asservissait son
peuple et détournait les milliards
depuis 24
ans on veut qu'il dégage qu'il dégage
merde qu'il
dégage la répression de la police va
faire 338 morts et plus de 2000 blessés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après 4 semaines de manifestation de
sitin de décembre 2010 à janvier 2011
les Tunisiens réussissent l'impensable
ils chassent un
dictateur Benali s'enfuit le 14 janvier
2011 en Arabie Saoudite un mois après
les premières
manifestations
Mohamed boisizi le vendeur ambulant n'a
pas survécu à ses blessures il est mort
en pleine révolution et n'a jamais connu
la portée de son
acte
le 25 janvier 2011 10 jours après la
chute de Benali le peuple égyptien
désespéré par la crise économique le
chômage et la corruption va marcher vers
la place tarir la place de la
Libération
[Applaudissements]
la révolution égyptienne suit la révolte
tunisienne mais elle est plus violente
plus
inventive elle sera la révolution d'un
pays de 90 millions d'habitants qui vont
chasser leur dictateur osni Mbarak au
pouvoir depuis 40
ans
[Applaudissements]
les jeunes qui symbolisent la révolution
égyptienne appartiennent à la classe
moyenne éduquée le monde occidental se
reconnaît en eux dans leur langage et
dans leurs
[Musique]
idéaux parmi eux certains vont devenir
les premiers martyres de la
Révolution leur mort va souder le peuple
égyptien contre le
[Musique]
régime lorsque les médicaments venaient
à manquer à la mosquée nous en
empruntions à l'église qui se trouve à
200 m d'ici et
inversement les musulmans avaient accès
à l'église pour y recevoir les premiers
soins et cela fait partie des plus beaux
cadeaux que la révolution nous est
offert fusion du peuple égyptien toute
communauté
confondue nous étions une seule et même
équipe le docteur venait travailler dans
notre hôpital et les nôtres allaient
chez eux on se passait des médicaments
et de l'équipement tout ce dont on avait
besoin ce qui nous a surpris c'est
qu'une fois soigné il retournait se
battre et ensuite il revenait à nouveau
blessé on les suppliait de rentrer chez
eux vous êtes vraiment en danger au nom
de Dieu s'il vous plaît
écoutez-nous nous avons été très touchés
par l'état d'esprit de ces jeunes gens
c'était des moments
[Applaudissements]
incroyables
ur la peur dis les jeunes de sur la
place etoran un monde de liberté qu' n'
jamais connu cette jeuneyptienne rêve de
démocratie sans pourutant penser au
lendemain politiquear doit partir c'est
[Musique]
tout le
clip la VO de la liberté devient l'hyne
de la
Révolution
ونكتب تاريخنا
بدمنا لو كنت واحد
مننا بلاش ترغي وتقول
[Musique]
لنا نمشي ونسيب
حلمنا وبطل تقول كلمه
انا في كل شع في
بلادي صوت الحريه بنادي
[Musique]
la place t rire symbolise la révolution
pourtant elle ne la représente pas les
jeunes militants urbains et diplômés de
la révolution 2.0 n'ont rien à voir avec
l'Égypte profonde qui veut bien se
débarrasser de Mbarak mais cherche
surtout à gagner sa
vie le dictateur va chercher à gagner du
temps il mise sur le réveil de l'Égypte
profond
c'est à elle qu' va s'ader et promre de
nouvelles élections ma première
responsabilité aujourd'hui c'est de
rétablir la sécurité et la stabilité du
pays pour effuer une transition
pacifique dans un climat favorable à la
protection de l'Égypte et des
Égyptiens nous transmettrons les
responsabilités à celui qui sera choisi
par le peuple au moment des prochaines
élections
Mbarak refuse de considérer les millions
de manifestants qui demandent son départ
il veut diviser le peuple et demande au
chamelier qui promè les touristes autour
des pyramides de foncer sur tar pour
faire place
nette les chamelers ruinés par la
révolution qui a fait fuir les touristes
lance
l'assaut
les manifestants surpris
rostentخصهصز السمال الحص ب مخصوص عشان
يضرب
[Applaudissements]
المظاهرين l'Égypte révolutionnaire
s'impose dans ces batailles face à
d'autres égyptiens miséreux payés par le
pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la révolution est en marche elle n'a
jamais été aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
forte en 2 semaines la violence fait
plus de 800
morts malgré ses victimes les jeunes de
tar refusent de lâcher prise devant la
détermination de la masse le dictateur
enfin le 11 février 2011 le
vice-président annonce la démission d'
[Musique]
Mbarak mes chers concitoyens dans les
circonstance difficile que traverse
notre pays le président Mohamad osni
Mbarak a décidé de renoncer à sa
fonction de président de la République
il a confié au Conseil supérieur des
forces armées la du PS so avec notre
pays et lui vien en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aide
seulement 18
[Applaudissements]
jours l'armée dirige maintenant le pays
en attendant les prochaines élections
entre alors en scène une organisation
islamiste la confrériie des Frères
musulmans opposant historique à tous les
pouvoirs égyptiens depuis les années 20
ilite
la et vont tout faire pour prendre le
pouvoir jours seulement après la ch dear
le M
lesef ven du qar transforme la place im
mosquée le prédicateur vient récupérer
la révolution au profit de la
confr تتهي ان الثوره بدات تت لا تظن ان
الثوره اعتبروا ان الثوره مستمره لانها
تشارك في البناء بناء مصر الجديده مصر
التي تعلمت من هذه الثوره الشيء الكثير
اصبروا على ورتكم وحافظوا عليها واياكم ان
يسرقها منكم
احد l'image d'une place tarire
religieuse chasse celle de la place
symbole de la liberté et de l'appel à la
démocratie la chaîne qatarie diffuse cet
événement dans tous les foyers du monde
arabe du Maghreb à la péninsule arabique
aljazira orchestre dès le lendemain de
la chute de Mbarak la récupération de la
Révolution par les Frères
musulmans
[Musique]
pendant la révolution égyptienne j'étais
tout le temps dans les locaux d'aljira
pour présenter différentes
émission car la révolution doit être
continuellement encouragée et les gens
avaient besoin d'écouter mes
paroles les frères m'ont dit vos
déclarations nous ont donné du courage
et nous ont protégé
elles nous ont réconforté dans notre
combat nous sur la place tarir et
partout ailleurs ces révolutions nous
les faisons quand notre ardeur faiblit à
chaque fois vous reprenez la parole et
des gens venus de partout nous
rejoignent en Égypte la lutte pour le
pouvoir va commencer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 jours après la démission de SNI Mbarak
la Libye est le trème pays touché par la
vague des printemps arabes sur cet
immense territoire producteur de pétrole
10 fois moins peuplé que l'Égypte la
révolution commence le 15 février 2011
ici dans la ville de Bengazi à l'est du
pays sur cette place baptisé elle aussi
la place tarir pendant 40 ans Mamar
khadfi a terrorisé la population
multiplier les pendaisons gaspiller
l'argent du pétrole dans d'improbables
aventures militaires et financer le
terrorisme dans le monde
entier en Libye à la différence de la
Tunisie et de l'Égypte la révolution va
tourner à la guerre et va durer 8
[Musique]
mois tout a commencé à Bazi par le geste
fou d'un homme descendu seul dans la rue
pour demander la chute de kadfi
le courage inoui de ce premier
manifestant est l'étincelle qui va
lancer la révolution
libyenne Mohamed naem un habitant de
Bengazi qui a participé à la révolution
était dans la rue à ce
momentl une personne d'une quarantaine
d'années petit de c tout mince et c'est
là qui a
[Musique]
dit
c'est là que quand s tous unis avec
cette personne et qu'on a commencé à
hurler le peuple veut faire tomber le
régime les premiers manifestants
marchent jusqu'au quartier général de
Kadafi à
[Applaudissements]
Bengazi
les soldats répondent à ce rassemblement
pacifique par des tirs à la mitrailleuse
lourde un des jeunes filme la scène
comme il le peut dans la
[Applaudissements]
panique il y a des jeunes qui ont enlevé
leur chemis et qui ont enlevé leur
pantalons et ils ont sauté dedans dans
la caserne juste pour montrer qu'on est
on est pas armé qu'on est ici s c'està
dire on est
venu faire une révolution nous on a
voulu une révolution mais eux ils ont
voulu une guerre donc ils ont eu la
guerre le lendemain les jeunes
retournent devant la caserne ils se sont
armés dans la nuit de cocktail Molotof
de pierre et
d'exlosif ils vont réussir l'impensable
prendre d'assaut la caserne
un des lieux de terreur dans lesquel
kadfi faisait torturer et exécuter ses
[Musique]
opposants si c'est une conspiration
intérieure ou extérieure nous allons
l'écraser si c'est un complot militaire
nous allons l'éliminer nous allons le
détruire avec du peuple libien et des
tribus libiennes qui vont s'unir pour un
seul combat la libération de chaque
parcelle du
[Musique]
pays Gaddafi envoie ses chars écraser la
ville rebelle il menace son peuple mais
il est isolé sur la scène
internationale un mois après le début de
la Révolution l'ONU autorise le recours
à la force pour protéger les libien
Londres et Paris envoie des avions de
chasse détruire les blindés qui menacent
[Musique]
Bengazi ces bombardements au nom du
d'ingérance pour sauver la population
libyenne sont aussi une occasion
inespérée pour l'Occident de se
débarrasser enfin de Kaddafi
l'incontrôlable sur aljazira qui a pris
F cause pour la Révolution le Youssef
elardai va galvaniser les
libiens le prédicateur qui avait fait
prier la place tar prononce une fat
contre
kadfi
cet homme veut anéantir le peuple et moi
je suis celui qui protège le peuple
j'appelle par cette F tous ceux qui
peuvent le faire à lui tirer dessus et à
débarrasser la libe et son noble peuple
de cet individu sé et
dangereux la f du donne le signal de la
trque deadfi son assassinat est
maintenant légal au nom de Dieu
les rebelles ont reçu des armes du Qatar
et se sont équipés en pillant les
armuries du régime la chasse à l'homme
commence les combattants de la
Révolution malgré quelques défaite vont
faire tomber une à une les villes
libyennes soustraites au contrôle de
kadfi les combats sont acharnés fron il
faut vaincre ou mourir une grande
majorité des jeunes s'engage et apprend
sur le terrain à manier des armes de
toutes
sorte mais kadfi ne cède pas depuis la
capitale Tripoli il exécute ses
opposants et envoie toujours ses chars
contre son
peuple il lance une vague d'arrestation
parmi les internautes qui soutiennent le
soulèvement on peut être arrêté pour un
tweet ou un appel relayé sur Facebook
Mohamed Ben Lamine peintre et sculpteur
de missrata est emprisonné avec son
frère un blogueur opposant du régime
placé sous écoutes
téléphonique ils avaient un ép dossier
où tous nos textos et nos conversations
téléphoniques étaient regroupé et
imprimé il nous emmenait pour des
interrogatoires pendant lesquels il nous
torturaient ou nous menaçait avec des
armes certains d'entre nous sont morts
sous la torture et d'autres à cause du
manque de soins médic
ils étaient sur les ner parce que jour
après jour ils se rendaient compte
qu'ils étaient en train de perdre la
guerre il devenait furieux et il se
défoulait sur nous les prisonniers
[Musique]
d'abouslim Mohamed Ben Lamin est enfermé
dans la prison d'abous slim à Tripoli
entre ces murs en
1996 plus de 1200 prisonniers islamiste
pour la plupart avaiit été massacré par
les forces spéciales de
Kaddafi dans cet univers qui symbolise
l'horreur du régime pour ne pas devenir
fou pour tenir BENLAMINE dessine sur les
murs de la cellule dans laquelle il
restera 4 mois jusqu'à la fin de la
[Musique]
guerre
les Tau se resser autour de Kaddafi
après 6 mois de combat fin août 2011 les
brigades des révolutionnaires ven de
toutes les villes libéré se coordonn et
l l'ASS final sur
Tripoli ils sont rejoint par une troup
de 600 libiens rentr d'exil pour
l'ultime
combat
le dictateur vit réfugié dans son palais
dévasté par les missiles dans un dernier
discours il fulmine contre le Qatar et
aljzira faisant appel en vain à l'unité
arabe dont il avait été le champion
adulé autrefois sans comprendre que la
révolution aujourd'hui se fait contre
lui ces chaînes de télévision arabe son
notre plus grand ennemi elle vous
encourage à détruire les puits de
pétrole à détruire la liberté à anéantir
le pouvoir du peuple à détruire la
Libye mais la Libye est une forteresse
mondiale est-ce que vous avez un
problème avec
moi merci à nos frères du Qatar est-ce
que c'est ça le sang et la fraternité
qui nous lit au lieu d'être de notre
côté vous êtes contre nous mais l'heure
de l'action a sonné en avant marche
l'heure de la victoire a sonné la
M fin août Tripoli tombe enfin au mains
des insurgés mais kadfi a déjà fui les
rebelles P son palais de babia un bqu
immense le dictateur vivait entouré de
son
harem
il s'est réfugié entouré des membres de
sa tribu et de ses mercenaires dans sa
ville natale de Sir pour l'ultime
[Musique]
bataille
encerclé dans sa ville détruite Kaddafi
va encore une fois essayer de sauver sa
peau il va fuir avec son escorte dans un
convoi de 44 rempli d'armes son évasion
est arrêtée nette par une frappe de l'OT
temp celui qui avait traité les
révolutionnaires de rat est capturé
caché dans un
[Musique]
égoutût lyché par la foule kadfi a une
mort abjecte à la mesure de l'horreur
qui
l'inspirait sans doute une manière
d'exorciser la terreur superstitieuse
qu'il exerçait tant qu'il était
[Applaudissements]
vivant
[Musique]
la révolution libyenne a duré 8 mois et
aurait fait 25000
morts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 18 mars 2011 3 mois après la Tunisie
la Syrie est le 4è grand pays arabe à
s'embraser
li pour s'inscrire à le tour dans
printemp arabe plein de promess pour
demander la démocratie dans un pays où
la familleassad est au pouvoir depuis 40
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ansécéou faisant des centaines de morts
arrêt et torture des milliers de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
manifestants en un mois le mouvement
s'étend à tout le pays sa répression est
terrible le pouvoir multiplie les
[Musique]
massacres voilà c'était notre maison qui
était aussi la maison de mon
frère ils ont brûlé la maison de mon
frère parce qu'il a soutenu la
révolution parce qu'il a réclamé la
liberté on peut même plus dormir dans
nos lits jusqu'au tapis sur lesquels on
s'asseyait tout a été
brûlé 4 mois après les premières
manifestations un groupe d'officiers
désertes et créé l'Armée syrienne libre
pour protéger la population
elle recrute des volontaires pour
combattre quelques commerçants
professeurs étudiants ou paysans qui
vont se battre comme ils le pourront
face au tueurs professionnel du régime
une armée de BRI et de
broc on a vendu tout l'or de nos femmes
pour acheter ces armes et on y a mis
toutes nos
économies les autres armes viennent de
prise de guerre de l'armée syrien
libre j'ai quitté l'université j'ai
rejoint l'armée libre dans mon village
la brigade des hommes libres de kerbet
Al Jose si le veut soit nous vaincrons
soit nous tomberons en martyre nous nous
battrons dans la voie d'Allah jusqu'à la
dernière goutte de notre
sang malgré leur détermination et leur
courage les soldats de la première heure
de l'Armée syrienne libre ne
parviendront pas à faire tomber Bachar
al-Assad le peuple syrien va devenir
l'otage d'un conflit régional qui le
dépasse dans lequel vont s'affronter les
deux grands courants de l'islam les
sunites majoritaires et les chiites
iraniens qui vont venir combattre au
côté de Bachar
etassad l'Union mondiale des savants
musulmans a déclaré qu'il devait y avoir
un soulèvement contre Bachar
al-Assad il doit être arrêté et
tué le cheik Youssef El kardaoui
intervient comme il l'avait fait en
Égypte et en libyie en direct sur
aljzira dans son émission la charia et
la vie il appelle à nouveau à
l'élimination du
dictateur une façon d'installer dans
chaque pays dès le début des révolutions
les Frères musulmans au cœur de la
conquête du
pouvoir leur sponsor est le
Qatar le cheik kardaoui chef spirituel
des Frères musulmans joue un rôle
fondamental dans l'alliance de la
confrériie avec le Qatar égyptien
naturalisé qatari il vit à DOA où
l'émire a mis à sa disposition la chaîne
de télévision aljazira devenu sa tribune
médiatique
le Qatar joue un rôle central danses
Révolution il est rapidement devenu le
portedrapeau de toutes les
révolutions que ce soit en Égypte en
libe au
Yémen il leur a offert de l'argent des
hommes les médias il le a offert tout ce
dont elles avaient besoin
plantique
CS l'émire du Qatar s'est senti menacé
par les révolutions la peur de les voir
se propager au monarchies du Golfe
Persique plutôt que de les combattre il
a choisi de les contrôler et a financer
les Frères musulmans comme il achète des
équipes de football le Qatar se retrouve
dans leur idéologie religieuse et
conservatrice il voi en eux le meilleur
moyen d'établir sur le Nouveau Monde
Arabe une domination politique serait
enfin à la hauteur de sa puissance
financière en Égypte les Frères
musulmans vont mettre plus d'un an à
conquérir le pouvoir les
révolutionnaires eux ont quitté la place
des jeunes activistes se sont dispersés
incapables de s'organiser dans la lutte
politique depuis le départ de Moubarak
les forces armées dirigent le
pays les Frères musulmans apparaissent
comme la seule force
alternative la confrerie est une
organisation disciplinée et structurée
par des années de clandestinité
elle offre depuis des années à la
population des munis des services
sociaux des dispensaires médicaux des
écoles pour de nombreux égyptiens elle
remplace depuis longtemps déjà un État
défaillant et
corrompu Gamal elritani est un des plus
grands écrivains égyptiens souvent
menacé de mort par les islamistes les
plus radicaux dont il dénonce la
violence et le
terrorisme
les Frères musulmans n'avaient au départ
aucun rapport avec la révolution bien au
contraire pendant les qure premiers
jours on les a pas vu sur la place tire
il n'y avait que quelques jeunes frères
musulmans venus à titre individuel qui
s'étent rebellés contre leur
hiérarchie les frères ne sont sortis de
leur réservve que lorsqu'ils ont compris
que la vague était suffisamment
puissante et qu'elle pourrait leur
permettre de réaliser leur
projets en novembre 2011 quelques
égyptiens s'installent à nouveau place
tir à la veille des élections
législatives pour réclamer au pouvoir un
scrutin transparent pour les militaires
qui dirigent le pays l'ordre doit régner
et le temps n'est plus au
manifestation 5000 policiers et militair
des forces antimeut Atta un campement de
200 personnes
placeulc par cette agression les jeunes
redescendent dans la
rue
[Applaudissements]
c'est la bataille de l'avenue Mohamed
Mahmoud elle durera 5 jours et fera 58
morts d'autres violences vont
[Applaudissements]
suivre
sur les murs du CER le soutien gorge
bleue de la jeune manifestante bastonnée
va devenir le symbole de la déchéance de
[Musique]
l'armée le général armed Chafik dernier
Premier ministre de Mbarak et candidat
de l'armée aux futures élections
présidentielles relvera
pas les Frères musulmans s'imposent en
alternative crédiible ils remportent
même les élections
législatives la confrerie infiltré dans
tous les échelons de la société va
pousser son candidat Mohamed Morsi vers
la présidence de la
républiquect je soutiens le docteur
Mohamed Morsi il a une excellente
interprétation de l'islam et il le gère
parfaitement je ne vois aucune raison
pour que quiconque a peur de
l'Islam en juin 2012 les Égyptiens
votent pour le second tour des élections
présidentielles dans la province du Faou
à 100 km au sud du Ker bastion des
Frères musulmans les électeurs se sont
mobilisés
ل pour la personne qui garantira un État
laïque parce qu'on a besoin d'entré
d'argent pour le pays de tourisme de
commerce une personne qui développera
notre
pays il nous faut
un vous avez bien compris pour qui j'ai
voté le docteur Mor est un homme bien et
nous espérons qu'il pourra nous aider et
nous le surveillerons et à la première
erreur nous luions non ça suffit vous
devez changer votre équipe en on
espère PRC qu' s'agit de ton avis
personnelle tique dans la religion
compris tu restes dans la politique soit
tu parles de politique soit tu es en
dehors c'est bon j'exprime mon opinion
il exprime l'opinion d'un seul individu
c'est
clair la plupart des gens sont d'accord
avec
moi les autres là ont un point de vue
différent car ils appartiennent à
l'Ancien
Régime ils veulent que l'Ancien Régime
reste au pouvoir ce sont des
profiteurs ils ont suffisamment volé et
on veut que ça
cesse va gagner c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sûr dès le soir du second tour les
Frères musulmans revendi la victoire ils
envoi leur partisans occuper la placeire
par peur d'un coup d'É
la place symbole de la révolution est
maintenant remplie d'hommes barbus et de
femmes
[Applaudissements]
voilé gloire le sang des martyres n'a
pas coulé en V je dis au doctur vous
êtes maintenant le seul protecteur de
chacun de nous sur le sol éyptien
n entier Comand l'islam gouverne il
gouverne par la justice il gouverne par
la liberté gouver par la justice
sociale ils sont même rejo par quelques
jeunes d'extrême gauche qui ont voté Mor
par du
général on est sur la place aujourd'hui
pour qu'on se souvienne de la ferveur
révolutionnaire contref pourter la chute
de l'Anci régime de la dictat per la
parce que pour la première fois depuis
7000 ans nous avons un président élu
grâce à la légitimité
révolutionnaire le peuple a voté en
majorité pour les Frères musulmans qui
ont été des prédateurs de la
Révolution ils ont réussi car les jeunes
rebelles n'étaient pas
organisés les jeunes de Facebook qui ont
lancé la révolution se sont ensuite
divisés en de nombreux
groupes certains d'entre eux sont
devenus des stars de to
télévisé d'autres sont rentrés au
Parlement comme députés et aujourd'hui
ils sont
dispersésandat frres musulmans n' gagné
517% des
VO Égypte reste donc un pays
profondément divisé dont le peuple
n'hésite plus à descendre dans la rue
face à la crise économique au chômage
les frères vont devoir prouver que leur
islam est la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
solution
en juillet 2012 un mois après les
Égyptiens les Libyens votent à leur tour
après 8 mois de guerre la reconstruction
est un immense défi dans un pays où
Kaddafi avait détruit toutes les
institutions politiquement après 40
années de dictature comment reconstruire
un pays en quelques Mo pour aider à
marcher vers la démocratie que la Libye
n'a jamais connu l'ONU a fourni du
matériel électoral en kit avec ses
isoloirs en carton et ses urnes de
plastique les Libyens vont élir leur
première Assemblée
nationale le soir des élections sur la
Place Verte de Tripoli c'est la fête
dans un paysùcun habitant en âge de
voter n'avait jamais pu choisir lui-même
librement ses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
représentants les dirigeants des
puissantes tribus celles de Zintan dans
la montagne de l'Ouest comme celle des
montagnes de l'est près de Bengazi
s'estiment exclus du processus alors
qu'ils ont lancé la
révolution ils ne font qu'une confiance
limitée aux nouveaux élus de Tripoli
chacun cherchant à jouer le plus grand
rôle dans la Libye nouvelle et se
méfiant des
autres la lib est une société avant
d'être une organisation
politique faut maintenant que cette
société se mette au service de
l'État notre réalité sociale se heurte
au concept même de la démocratie elle ne
peut pas s'appliquer aux sociétés arabes
parce qu'elle a été conçue pour des
sociétés civiles occidentales
[Musique]
libérales pour nous les idéologies
libérales sont très difficiles à
accepter elles sont appréciées par les
jeunes mais nous n'en voulons pas il va
y avoir un affrontement entre le
libéralisme et la politique voilà ce qui
nous menace car nous ne sommes pas des
démocrates nous n'avons jamais vécu dans
une atmosphère
[Musique]
démocratique aujourd'hui en Libye le
pays est ingouvernable une coalition
d'une cinquantaine de partis politiques
a remporté les élections sans réussir à
former une majorité l'argent du pétrole
suscite toutes les convoitises chaque
région productrice veut en contrôler les
revenus il n'y a plus d'armée ni de
police la réalité du pouvoir est détenue
par les tribus mais aussi depuis la
guerre par les Milic certaines sont
affiliées à Al-Qaïda elles ont récupéré
d'énormes stocks d'armes et refusent de
se soumettre à l'autorité de
l'État
[Musique]
en Tunisie ont été organisé le 23
octobre 2011 les premières élections qui
fais suite au printemps
arabe dans ce pays la lacité reste
profondément ancré dans la classe
moyenne des grandes
villes le par des frres musulans est
arriv ente maisir la
majorité on bénéfici comme en Égypte du
prestige de la répression dont ils ont
été victime sous la
dictature c'est la victoire d'un parti
discipliné face à l'éparpillement des
partis
laïques la petite ville l'imolation de
Mohamed a donné le départ des printemps
arabes la situation sociale n' pas
fondamentalement changé depuis que le
partiarda dirige le pays le chômage n'a
fait qu'augmenter
on a statufié la charrette du marchand
ambulant sur la place du gouvernor là où
il mais l'esprit de la révolution est
lo les habitants de trouv que leur
région reste marginalisé et ce depuis
des
années nos infrastructures sont les
pires et les plus vustes de toute la
République le taux de pauvreté y est
toujours particulièrement
élevé
chôage tous les jeunes sont
touchés et le nombre de jeunes diplômés
chômeurs augmente tous les ans de plus
de
[Musique]
5000 dans ce berceau des printemps
arabes les associations de diplômés
chômeurs rassembl les jeunes
universitaires qui ne trouvent pas de
travail souvent engagé à l'extrême
gauche sont ell avec les syndicalistes
locaux qui ont transformer l'immolation
spectaculaire de boisizi en un mouvement
de révolution aujourd'hui ces
révolutionnaires de la première heure se
sentent TR et reste mobilisé contre le
pouvoir avant nous pouvions espérer un
salaire de 5000 ou 10000 dinars ce qui
nous Assur un minimum aujourd'hui nous
pouvons même plus espér ag une telle
somme et cela a des conséquences sur
toutes nos conditions de vie vous voulez
un are exemple on peut rester
célibataire jusqu'à 40 ans Tunisie
pourquoi moiême je suis célibataire
alors que j'ai 34 ans et ce n'est pas
par choix j'aimerais bien me marier mais
j'en ai pas les moyens matériels le
mariage c'est des responsabilités une
femme et des enfants à nourrir vu les
conditions actuelles c'est
impossible
soci no manifestations sont par les
salistes je suis sû qu'on les laisse
faire
délibérément il ce qu'il veulent ils
attaquent les fou le peuple Tux qui
défendent la liberté la dignité et Tux
qui ESS juste de
vivre les salapfistes sont des
intégristes violents qui militent pour
l'islamisation totale de la
société ils sont soutenus par l'Arabie
Saoudite leur stratégie consiste à
récupérer le mécontentement social avec
un slogan simpliste l'islam est la
solution ils veulent éliminer les
militants de la gauche laïque et font
pression sur le parti au pouvoir
etarda devant la mosqué ils organisent
des quêtes pour leurs frères de Syrie
pris dans la guerrees ftiques
les salistes de appartienent au
mouvement des partisans de la charia un
groupe radical dirigé par qui a
travaillé avec
benad
in grande mosqué de la
ville notre volonté est d'arriver à
faire Triomph la religion nous sommes de
jeunes pratiants nous sommes très
nombreux et nous ne voulons pas de la
démocratie qui n'est pas reconnu par
l'Islam cette démocratie délèg le
pouvoir au peuple et si le peuple veut
désobéir Allah il le peut pour nous il
faut obéir le toutpuissant que ce soit
lui qui régisse tout les petites choses
comme les
grandes
[Musique]
à Tunis le Premier ministre Amad Jebali
peine à gouverner son pays pris entre
deux
feux d'un côté la pression intégriste
salafiste difficile à gérer pour ce
partisan déclaré d'un islamisme dit
modéré et de l'autre le défi de
l'aggravation de la situation sociale
qui fait dire au tunisiens que rien n'a
changé depuis la
[Musique]
révolution c'est pas facile il faut être
réaliste ils savent très bien que ce
sont des
problèmes structure structure c'est pas
conjoncturel ils oublient qu'on a
vraiment rité de tous ces problèmes et
que ces problèmes maintenant se sont
amplifiés
maintenant par la Révolution elle-même
c'est-à-dire on a les voir on a Libé le
demande lib les espoir même il y a un
plafond maintenant placé là-bas est
placé très
haut sur le front des libertés publiques
pour rassurer notamment les partis de la
gauche laïque de sa coalition
gouvernementale Amadi Jebali a créé un
ministère des Droits de l'Homme une
première en Tunisie il a confié le
portefeuille à Samir Dilou un membre des
Narda qui peine à convaincre de
l'utilité de son cabinet
le ministre des Droits de l'Homme va
vite devoir faire ses preuves face à la
multiplication des exactions extrémistes
qui perturbe la vie politique
[Musique]
tunisienne les salafistes attaquent
toutes les formes d'expression des
libertés individuelles ils s'opposent à
l'islam populaire
tunisien eux qui veulent soumettre la
population à l'intégrisme considèrent
les marabou ces tombeau des sains de
l'Islam comme de
l'hérésie ces mausolées sont une cible
de ces fanatiques qui ont dynamité de
nombreux autres lieux de religion popula
à travers la
[Musique]
Tunisie
l'alcool et la liberté des meurs sont
his par les
salafistes en septembre 2012 ils ont
saccagé l'hôtel orchani
àide inauguré en mars 1976 à l'époque où
la Tunisie se réclamait de la laïcité
c'était le dernier lieu où l'on vendait
de la bière légalement dans la bourgade
où est née la
révolution ils sont venus casser le
bar toutes les les bouteilles qu'il y a
ils ont monté aux chambres ils ont cassé
les chambres ils ont foncé les chambres
carrément ils ont cassé toutes toutes
les les les salons de du bar ils étaient
aussi à la réception ils ont tout
[Musique]
cassé
u la révolution depuis la mort de bois
vous demandé combien de personnes ont
fin combien de Mor complètement sous il
y en a plein combien de personnes sont
suicid parce ét il y en a beaucoup
combien de Bu on malag avec leurs
parents combien de personnes ont commisl
des crimes après avoir consommé de
l'alcool et surtout combien de femmes
ont été enlevées et par des hommes
[Musique]
ivres les artistes sont une autre cible
des
salafistes en juin 2012 ils ont saccagé
une exposition dans la banlieue de Tunis
dont il jugeait les œuvres exposées
offensantes pour
l'islam parmi celle-ci l'installation de
la sculptrice Nadia
Gassie trois mannequins de femmes voilé
émergeant d'un monticule de Pierre
enveloppé dans des journaux contenant de
la propagande islamiste l'œuvre évoque
les lapidations des femmes soupçonnées
d'adultère en
[Musique]
Afghanistan non seulement les fanatiques
l'ont dénoncé comme une incitation à
jeter des pierres aux femmes voilées
mais en plus ils ont déposé plainte pour
trouble à l'ordre
public
un jour je reçois un coup de fil d'une
dame qui se présente en tant que
secrétaire du juge d'instruction qui me
demande si je voulais bien me présenter
devant le juge et il me reçoit et il me
dit madame vous êtes accusé pour avoir
exposé des images entraînant la
perturbation de l'ordre public donc si
l'instruction arrive jusqu'au procès ça
serait une première une Tunisie une
sorte de jurisprudence ça serait la
première fois où un artiste
euh euh serait in enfin pass irit en
prison pour avoir exposé un travail et
et les frontières c'est à moi de les
définir à personne d'autre à aucun
pouvoir ni politique ni religieux ni
aucun autre pouvoir et ça c'est ça c'est
ça c'est mon espace de liberté ça c'est
mon être monondte personne ne peut me
l'enlever personnellement je me retrouve
devant un malaise énorme pour moi euh
traduire un créateur en justice pour une
œuvre d'art c'est un affran à la
Révolution et au principe de la
Révolution le problème c'est que on est
en face d'une justice qu'on veut
indépendante euh je me sens un peu avec
les bras liés mais je vais tout faire
pour dépasser
euh cet épisode avec le moins le les
moindres dégâts mais je crains que le
mal est déjà fait
et pour moi une Tunisie qui qui se
respecte doit respecter ses créateurs
[Musique]
si Samir Dilou le ministre des Droits de
l'Homme témoigne d'un malaise impuissant
d'autres au sein des Narda souhaitent
que la justice poursuive les atteintes
au sacré Rached Rani le chef du parti
des Narda véritable homme fort de la
Tunisie décrié par les laïes pour ses
relations ambigues avec les salafistes
condamne fermement toutes les libertés
prises avec
l'islam
pour vire dans une société pacifiquement
il faut que chacun d'entre nous respecte
les croyances des
autres vous avez la liberté de croire ou
de ne pas croire en l'Islam et au Coran
ou même d'y apporter une critique
scientifique mais vous n'avez pas le
droit de vous en moquer comme par
exemple en écrivant le nom d'Allah sur
la semelle de vos
chaussures en imprimant des versets du
Coran sur des
sousvêtements pourquoi faire des choses
pareilles
ce sont des actes
diaboliques actes diaboliques qui ne
servent qu'à une chose provoquer les
[Musique]
musulmans les révolutionnaires qui ont
chassé Ben ne s'oppos pas à la laité
tunisienne il dénon simplement la
dictature dans la Tunisie d'aujourd'hui
le parti islamiste au pouvoir et les
salaistes Atta le modèle la hérit
indépendance en
1956 avant la révolution on voyait pas
autant de femmes voilé dans les ru de
Tunis le portab est devenu une des
principales revendications des
islamistes une prise en otage des femmes
pour mieux attaquer les idéaux de la
Révolution encore vivace dans ce
pays la Tunisie est divisé par deux
conceptions de la société
elle est menacé par la
rupture
[Musique]
ces victoires des Frères musulmans sont
un triomphe pour le
[Musique]
Qatar l'mira peut passer à la phase
suivante de sa stratégie politique
devenir le leader de ce nouveau monde
arabe islamique et
sunite pour ce petit pays c'est une
stratégie d'alliance ambitieuse pour
assurer sa sécurité face à ses puissants
voisins saoudiens et
iraniens pour servir ses intérêts
diplomatiques le Qatar organise en
septembre 2012 dans l'hôtel cheraton de
DOA deux conférences pour tenter de
convaincre les laïques arabes de
collaborer avec les Frères musulmans à
la constitution d'une grande nation
islamique les vedettes en sont les
principaux dirigeants des Frères
musulmans des radicaux qui il y a peu
tenz la démocratie pour la pire des
impiétés mchal du Hamas palestinien
favorable à la destruction
d'Israël rachan de
Tunisie souantien
d'alqïda Alani de
Syrie tous réunis avec la même ambition
cré une grande nation arabe sunite
dominé par les Frères
musulmans
une occasion unique pour le monde arabe
de créer un grand ensemble politique une
ambition à laquelle aljazira travaille
depuis sa création wfar a dirigé la
chaîne depuis la guerre d'irac en 2005
jusqu'à septembre
2011 je pense que nous allons enfin
pouvoir établir des relations communes
dans toute la
région
nous allons construire une société
fidèle à notre culture qui est vieille
de 1300 ou 1400
ans nous allons enfin prendre en main
notre propre évolution dont le pivot
sera
régional on ne suivra plus les modèles
occidentaux ou bien soviétique ni aucun
autre pour accomplir ce rêve de création
d'une grande nation arabe sunite il t un
dernier pays allié la
Syrie la Syrie est le seul pays des
printemps arabes qui n'a pas réussi à
chasser son tyran
la révolution y dure depuis 2 ans et le
dictateur Bachar al-Assad n'est toujours
pas tombé la révolte est devenue une
guerre civile meurtrière qui a fait près
de 80000 morts 1 million de Syriens ont
fu leur
pays la guerre est totale elle a frappé
partout dans les campagnes comme dans
toutes les grandes villes le souc d'Alep
le plus ancien du monde a été détruit la
vieille ville est restée des mois sous
les tirs des snipers de Bachar
[Musique]
alAssad le principal Atou militaire du
régime est la puissance de son armée de
l'air ces avions de chasse bombardent à
l'aveugle les zones de combat comme les
habitations les pilotes d'hélicoptère
largu des barils rempl de TNT et de
ferraill les
baramil
imprécis mais très dévastateur il
souffle les immeubles et tue les
habitants une arme de
terreur je dormais quand à l'aube un
avion a larguit un baril de TNT sur
notre maison la maison de mes beau
parents et a
détruite mon frère a perdu la vie sa
femme et ma belle mère mon second frère
et moi nous avons été blessés le village
de cafar a été bombardé avec plusieurs
barils de TNT et 15 personnes qui ont
perdu la vie en une seule
matinée
[Applaudissements]
les Assad gouvernent depuis 1970 par la
force Bachar elAssad a succédé à son
père en juillet 2000 il a hérité d'un
pouvoir assis sur la puissance d'un
parti unique d'un service de
renseignement à ses ordres et d'une
communauté soudée les alawites une secte
Chiite
à la différence de Mamar khadfi qui
combattait seul les révolutionnaires
Bachar alAssad a de grands alliés les
Russes et les Chinois engagés dans un
rapport de force avec l'Occident et
lesit iraniens than aide le régime
depuis le début de la révolte en Syrie
un soutien sans faille diplomatique et
militaire nous remercions en premier la
Russie la Chine et l'Iran les autres
pays qui nous soutiennent face aux
tentativ d'ingérance dans les affaires
intérieures syriennes le peuple syrien
les assure de son admiration et de sa
fidélité et de sa
[Applaudissements]
reconnaissance les alliés de Bachar
alAssad ont bloqué le vote de résolution
de l'ONU qui aurait une intervention de
l'OTAN comme en
Libye la faiblesse du soutien occidental
à l'insurrection s'explique aussi par la
proximité d'Israël du Liban et la peur
de voir un état islamiste succéder à
Bachar
elAssad l'Armée syrienne libre créée
pour résister à la répression sanglante
du régime s'est renforcé des milliers de
soldats et d'officiers de l'armée
régulière de Bachar al-Assad ont déserté
et rejo
s chaque déserteur officialise sa
défection en postant une vidéo sur
Youtube
Peret de dater carte d'identité à l'appu
le jour de son incorporation dans
l'Armée syrienne
libre je suis le colonel de l'É de
l' et voici ma carte d'identité le
colonel Kassem comme la majorité des
officiers qui a rejoint l'Armée syrienne
libre a une vision laïque et
démocratique de son
pays il est aujourd'hui le responsable
militaire de la ville de
hom le monde entier observe passivement
les destructions et les
tueries les calculs diplomatiques et les
règlements de compte entre les États se
font au détriment pe
sy tout ça c'est à cause de l'Ance
stratégique de la Syrie dans la
région c'est pour cette raison que la
victoire tarde à
venir personne vient sir la situation va
EMP non seulement en Syrie mais aussi
dans tout le
prochei sera incapable deôler cette
région qui sombra dans
l'extrémisme
l'attentisme des Occidentaux a laissé la
main libre au
Qatar avec l'Arabie Saoudite il finance
des groupes extrémistes des combattants
islamistes qui affrontent les mil de
Bachar etassad au nom du
des groupes dadistes syriens sont
aujourd'hui les plus riches et les mieux
armés il jou un rôle déterminant dans
les opérations
militaires
aussi diffusent des vidéos sur Internet
les film de leurs attentat pour
impressionner leur bailleur de fond du
golf et pour attirer des combattants du
monde
entier
Allahu Akbar Allahu Akbar
allahuakbar leik lebik lebbeik ya Allah
lebik lebik lebik ya Allah leik leik
leik ya Allah
Leuh
après l'Afghanistan et l'Irak la Syrie
est devenue à son tour une terre du
djihad dans les mosquées salafistes des
pays alentours les imams recrutent déjà
des combattants pour la nouvelle guerre
sainte comme ici au
Liban régime syrien contre le peuple
dans l'indifférence du monde a conduit
les Syriens à croire au dad et à se
battre les hommes les vieux les femmes
et les enfants ont pris les
ares an les syri é un peuple
mortun année pour faire un
peuple
avec l'aide des renforts djihadistes des
régions se libèrent une à une en Syrie
et au fil des villages reconquis les
combattant de la guerre sainte sont
acclamés en libérateur par la
[Musique]
population en Syrie le régime finira
sûement par tomber mais à quel
prix entre la dictature et le SAL
la voix reste étroite pour la démocratie
dans le monde arabe les populations qui
ont chassé leurs dictateurs vont-elles
se satisfaire des gouvernements
islamistes qu'ells ont élu en Égypte et
en Tunisie des manifestants sont à
nouveau descendus dans la rue pour
exprimer leur
mécontentement l'histoire des
révolutions arabes n'est pas jouée le
désir de justice sociale des populations
toujours touchées par le chômage et la
pauvreté reste fort la confiscation des
idéaux révolutionnaires qui avaient fait
des printemps arabes eso pour le monde
entier sera-elle sans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
retour